[Music]
in switching sides news submitted by
starving student I haven't heard that in
forever
is it every student starving starving
student starving artists I'll feed you
come here I know what the food in your
mouth I'll feed you a foreign police
chief who opposed legalizing marijuana
now runs a weed company after change of
heart how smart it's lucrative you
two-timing [ __ ] money but who better to
run a business like that who knows the
law yeah sure right so this Toronto
police chief former police chief oh he
was a police chief oh [ __ ] oh God she
we're gonna suck and sell it we yeah he
really knows she's got power over the
police like station still he's like a
stay off my [ __ ] I know you to put it
into perspective that's like a mayor
like the mayor of police the mayor of
police yeah leonie's he was recently
named executive chair of a medical
marijuana company and so his name is
Julian Fantino and so what a dope name
Julia poppy no he looks like he sounds
like he would either be part of the
police force or mafia or a restaurant
owner's name the name of the restaurants
oh yeah been Dino's would you like our
fried raviolis as our appetizer or maybe
a salad on the side where squash Ravin
little bread with balsamic and some
olive oil first press by the way little
pesto listen lady [ __ ] hungry right
rajat THC in this pasta blue and green
pasta he was super outspoken about like
not legalizing marijuana he would be
saying that we don't know enough of the
impact that marijuana has on humans he
said this back in 2003
oh it's enough time yeah so and then
like the most recent time that he was
opposing it was in 2015 nice shirt on
never mind yeah 2015 he tweeted out I am
completely opposed to a legalization of
marijuana but then after he talked to
some veterans and he found out the
benefits
marijuana for actually like the real
people that need marijuana for initial
yeah so he's saying like he used to
think that medical marijuana was just an
excuse for stoners - yeah they have some
like think you guys are pretending but
now it's real yeah after talking to
three veterans sure you got Parkinson's
show me the money yeah are you just
saying like now he sees how marijuana
really helps or he saw the paycheck and
he saw the light the right industry I
should be in right now good meaning to
tell me you could make half a million in
a month I'm in the wrong industry money
can change people dude I'm telling ya I
saw the light Paul was telling me the
story about his neighbor who lived in
the same street and you know San Jose is
getting really [ __ ] expensive had
this house he absolutely loved would
never [ __ ] sell it Chinese lady came
on his lawn she was like he's like what
are you doing get the [ __ ] off my
property she goes talk to my husband
husband comes up he goes I want to buy
her house he goes [ __ ] you my house
isn't for sale you know two million
dollars he goes I mean think about how
alcohol used to be super demonized like
your church probably would have never
talked to you if you [ __ ] drank and
and it was you know during Prohibition
it was just the gangsters doing that
[ __ ] man I wish I could drink and not
get that red thing cuz you know like it
makes you all loopy and [ __ ] cuz I see
everybody else drinking they look like I
suck it up
all I'm saying those like weed like
people don't have a really overdose on
it like you don't really go out and like
get vindictive or like cheat on somebody
or like kill somebody you're like you
just get lazy even like this cops
switching sides or whatever it's like
there's not really many cases where it's
like there's such crazy consequences
yeah the biggest thing you could say is
like weeds is a gateway drug but that's
like saying like no dude like that was a
gateway mentality like somebody just
that's how they are you know what I mean
yeah you probably were already curious
yeah yup I was I was curious yeah
you know over here he's saying that
marijuana is a healthier choice
especially now that there's this opioid
crisis where a lot of people are getting
addicted to painkillers and stuff and so
that's a pretty funny statement I know
you guys look you guys out there killing
people
just punch people yeah if you have to
kill someone just punch or kick someone
in the face yeah that's a funny
statement it is better it is but it's
like how about just don't do it yeah
municipal purposes only Oh what what the
hell are you saying
permanent pain and they're taking like I
hope you always to like relax teen
killer I thought he was just talking
about just like recreation gotcha so
he's famous or at least that's the fine
line in which we have to have a
conversation right yeah if this guy's
getting into it like the only thing you
talk about is his medical purpose well
that's what they can't see how [ __ ]
dope it is well it comes the named
executive chair is it is a medical
marijuana company gotcha slash if
they're naming him executive chair too
that could also be like a consulting
concept for like his legal know-how in
Palace right I mean this guy was like
former police chief so it's like tasks
something like that on your board of a
medical marijuana community legitimizes
it helpful and legitimate some money
talks too right they might as well Oh
fun was Fantino what if he got some type
of Hearts and then he started smoking
weed and he said I see you like really
started working closely with veterans or
what if they gave him money four million
dollars and say can you endorse this and
say that you worked with a bunch of
veterans and this is the right thing to
do it happened to we never know I just
like making up stories though cuz it
makes it more interesting yeah what's
this sorry a hundred percent he was
muscled down we come in he came up to is
it you better [ __ ] endorse this well
I'm a [ __ ] you with the app but I'm the
police [ __ ] matter Oh got in your
[ __ ] mouth or his ass just got broke
and he was just like damn that's money
like the industry right there like weed
right now legalization and
because like the dot-com boom era it's
not just like Oh more people are gonna
smoke weed now and like roll of joints
you know it's like now there's like room
for like weed vapes now there's room for
like - they're creating job [ __ ] yeah
batteries for vapes I think like that
industry blew up because like more
people were purchasing like THC vapes
you know insanity yeah the whole
spectrum and industry and every
extension of it is benefiting off of
business and industry it's not just weed
so I mean it's a dot-com era for it for
literally marijuana yeah and then so it
seems like pharmaceutical companies are
heavily against it obviously because
they're losing money if people turn more
to marijuana so then eventually
pharmaceutical companies are gonna go
into the medical marijuana industry I
bet that I hope they do well cause like
what she was saying like oh it opioids
and all that [ __ ] that I should not be
doing it spit that [ __ ] out right now
damn it
you gotta hope that right but then if
you look at oil companies they are they
don't want to really go into the
renewable energy because then that's
their competitor and so they're like no
we want to [ __ ] up the earth because we
make more money and just like with
humans and the pharmaceuticals we want
to [ __ ] up humans so then we make more
money yeah they make more money on
keeping us sick addicted if we're not
always sick then they're not giving us
medicine so it's in their best interest
to keep us always sick if we're cured
then they're not we're not taking
prescriptions everything that's how we
get the flu shot every year I don't just
give me the flu I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you pick my brains then get some [ __ ]
I don't know I hate getting a flu man
that's just terrible I know I only get
the flu when I get the flu shot I get
the flu shot I go down the next three
days somewhere so Mexicans are immune to
the flu you guys know you have a word
for it I think Mexicans are HIV proof -
HIV virus comes in and then your white
blood cells just have a sombrero and
like two shooters
[Laughter]
bow-bow-bow the only be Mexicans aren't
immune to his sperm pregnant doesn't
gotta go inside how come you're talking
all this [ __ ] when your wife and your
son are Mexican I just told you how how
far long and resilient your immune
system is that's always saying like just
take it and run girls never 3
[ __ ] over here no HIV no flu
and your sperm is so strong if you have
strong [ __ ] yeah yep yep yep strong
genetics yep now that meant to breathe
it is it is perspective age the sperm is
very polite can i press all STIs yeah
back on this whole drug talk they'll
have you guys heard of a cretonne cred
oh no what is that it's an herbal
supplement a lot of people are using it
to fight opioid addiction Oh
the FDA they're trying to get it to be a
Schedule one drug of course
yeah can you also tell me what schedule
1 drug means yeah so there's different
levels of how illegal something is yeah
so like Schedule one is like cocaine
heroin like that level [ __ ] yeah and so
what this herbal supplement does it it
gives you sort of like like a head
change and it kind of gives you that
like euphoric feeling - like all the
other crazy effects that like heroin
gives you so a lot of people are using
this to kick heroin addiction and so now
the government's trying to control that
- and it's like dude we're trying to
here people here with natural
supplements and the government's like
nah but how are we gonna make money yeah
that's you know because you know the
[ __ ] secret is if you just eat
healthy and exercise the human body is
capable of [ __ ] amazing things yeah
yeah burgers man they just make your
soul feel good though cuz I broccoli
just kills my soul dude you're
interested you guys gotta check out some
like vegan diets and sylvie no [ __ ]
veganism
don't want to lose my ball sacks yeah I
like you know what I'm on the climb they
look smoother than ever my skin's eager
you you you can do it really good you
can be a omnivore but try your best to
fill your food like failure your diet up
with fresh produce lots of fiber fruits
vegetable you can eat meat but make sure
it's like fresh and good perspective
first well I mean I mean I guess it just
depends on your stand plans could be
another topic conversation but there are
ethical and healthy ways to consume meat
too though I'm just like food I don't
give a [ __ ] don't tell me what to eat
[ __ ] but veganism not asking I don't
hate anything about veganism I just like
different food Feroze are vegan now I'm
on do you diet how long have you been
being it's so hard to be like your arm
vegan because I feel like there's even
like a you know a perspective Oris
because it's what your practice but you
don't completely identify yourself with
yeah you can't even be vegan if you're
wearing leather shoes for only a week
yeah but it's like it's refreshing right
it's like it's it's different especially
as a dancer - it's like okay cool I have
more energy during the day or like I
don't feel heavy or I feel I could move
faster like just things like that and
I'm like that makes sense and I'll like
leave it at that I don't need to be like
a I don't need to go out and parade like
this vegan flag or tell my making the
word vegan has such a negative [ __ ]
connotation to it it's like vegan oh
you're one of those [ __ ] Nazis yeah
you know but the vegan diet all it is is
just a fresh vegetables not gonna be
like oh my god you eat meat I look less
at you you know what I mean like I look
down on you it's not like anything for
me because I'm bigger than you that's
why
[Music]